[Music]
the predator sees humanity face off
against the intergalactic race of
hunters once more directed by Shane
Black the franchise returns to its roots
and possesses an ending that definitely
needs dissecting throughout this video I
will be discussing the ending of the
predator as well as the film's plot
there will be heavy spoilers and this
movie is definitely worth seeing with
fresh eyes if you're a fan of the
franchise without the way I'm definition
and I ruin the movie so you don't have
to be the predator focuses on a predator
known as the fugitive trying to evade
capture from a larger more dominant
version of the species the fugitive has
stolen a weapon that will allow humanity
to have more of a fighting chance
against the alien hunter race illusions
of Prometheus gifting humanity with fire
and being punished by the gods are clear
from the outset and there is definitely
a mythological feeling to the work we
discover that the weapon is a combat
suit called the predator killer or will
even the playing field as it has the
predator technology woven into it and
can be worn by humans whilst the reason
of why the fugitive wants humanity to
take this weapon is unknown I believe it
is because the more dominant version of
the predator is slowly starting to stamp
out the lesser species back home in the
film predators which preceded this movie
there was a definite tension between the
two and it makes sense that there would
be a civil war between them the fugitive
knows that alone his race cannot stop
the larger upgrades
however with humanity's help they may be
able to at the film's end the humans
managed to kill the giant predator and
we flash forward many years to discover
that humanity is working on several
elements of technology in order to fight
the war against them the final shot of
the film the researchers finally managed
to open the pod that encases the weapon
and the armor is shot out it attaches to
a human and adapts to fit him out fully
with a suit that can fight the invaders
that are likely to be coming it's an
ambiguous ending that teases more of
what could happen rather than give a
definitive
and but I have a theory on where they
may take it personally I think the
sequel will go either one or two ways I
believe that it will either continue on
earth with a huge showdown between
humanity and the Predators that tears
the planet in two or that humans will
journey to the Predators planet and take
them head-on
while sue manatee is unaware of exactly
where the Predators come from they may
be able to track the people that
regularly go missing and are transported
to predator on planets like the ones we
saw in the film predators this would be
a great callback to the third film in
the franchise and I'd love to see Adrian
Brody's character return as he is
currently stranded on that planet
predator for me is a series that is
missing several cameos and I think the
fans deserve to see some returning
characters in the original script for
the film all swatching ago was intended
to have a cameo at the end in which he
would reunite with the humans and enlist
them in a war against the Predators
however this plot point was dropped when
the actor turned it down it would have
been a great addition and though they
were unable to make it happen I hope
that they can have returning characters
in further sequels so what did you think
of the predator did you enjoy the reveal
of the predator killer suit or do you
think that the studio are desperately
trying to turn this into a superhero
movie rather than an action horror that
it used to be comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and subscribe to my
channel I create content like this
weekly and they'll definitely be
something on here that you love if
you're a fan of film make sure you check
out my ending explained video for the
none linked at the end of this one and
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]